[Music]
having anxiety is like having a friend
who just never leaves your side it's
like having a shadow that is very very
real even when it's dark out it's not
like you invite this friend to come
along with you everywhere you go but
they just come along
[Music]
you tell you that I have starts
generally in my chest and I feel this
sense of constriction it feels kind of
like if you go running without eating
give me you're kind of exhausted and
you're having trouble just like getting
a full breath and you're also feeling
kind of faint because you haven't eaten
that's kind of the way that it feels for
me but it's like full-time for like
several months it feels like a really
cold hand is coming from my stomach up
my spine of my neck and is kind of
scraping at my head and I start to think
that the hand is starting to make my
body work against me I can't just get
over it I can't just tell myself this is
crazy like I can't I do every day you
know say like wow this is really
illogical and like really doesn't make
that but at the end of the day it's
still there and the fear that you feel
about mundane things or hypothetical
things is very real it affects you and
really real ways
[Music]